dr. strange you think you know how the  world works what if I told you the  reality you know is one of many  this doesn't make any sense  not everything does not everything has  to  for the mystic arts we harness energy  and shape reality  we travel great distances in an instant  I get from here to there how did you  become a doctor studying practice yours  there's a strength to him but is he  ready  be careful which paths you travel down  strange stronger man than you have but  away  death and pain  we'll dive tackle as well  I can't give it there is no other way  I've spent so many years  peering through time  looking for you  but what's this my mantra it's the Wi-Fi  password we're not savages  you've spent your life trying to widen  it